in a market humans with unlimited wants
often meet sellers with limited supplies
in such a place competition is usually a
force of good it leads to more Choice
increases the quality of products on
offer and reduces their prices if
competition is absent monopolies can
form and that's a problem
Adam Smith the father of modern
economics defined competition as
allocating productive resources to their
most highly valued uses
for sellers the money they receive when
they sell is more productive than their
product for the buyers the produce they
get is more productive than their money
when a deal is done neither party may be
entirely happy with the agreed price but
at the end both feel better off
in a competitive market those who want
something the most end up getting it
competition takes various forms as the
following story illustrates
one dealer in a market decides to bring
in bananas to be the first to sell them
he is the only one and since people love
bananas he sells them at a high price
and it doesn't take long for someone
else to see an opportunity for
improvement
[Music]
competing in price is the most
straightforward way in which sellers can
compete for customers because consumers
usually prefer to pay less in order to
survive the first seller also known as
incumbent may also lower the prices this
pressure on prices is usually leaving
customers better off in theory this back
and forth will continue until both have
reached a price that yields zero profit
then one may decide to close
but there is also non-price competition
instead of offering a lower price
newcomers can try to sell higher quality
products or innovate in response to
innovators incumbents may try to improve
their offers and come up with ideas to
strengthen their position both may
increase their service hours so besides
lowering prices another consequence of
competition is the range of choices and
Innovation both of which are good for
the people in the market
in a free market competition defines the
ultimate price and quality of goods on
offer a phenomenon referred to as
emergent order that means it's
eventually not up to the shop to decide
how much to charge for a product but
intangible forces such as Supply demand
and consumer preferences that emerge
over time if one company is the only one
selling a product we speak of a monopoly
then the benefits of competition fade
and the naturally emergent order gets
disrupted
from perfect competition to Monopoly
lies a spectrum we can use to define the
intensity of competition in a highly
transparent Market we have almost
perfect competition with low prices and
lots of customer choice in a market that
is dominated by a monopoly prices are
often High and the variety of options
decreases if just a few companies share
the market we speak of oligopoly which
is also a problem as they often secretly
fix prices
in a free and open market with high
competition we see Innovative suppliers
happy customers and an immersive variety
of choice
on the other end of the spectrum we have
a monopoly suppliers have little
bargaining power the goods they sell are
often inferior customers pay higher
prices and wait longer hours
[Music]
in order for markets to function
governments need to break monopolies up
and consumers should support those that
rival them only then will we see
Innovation good products low prices
happy customers and markets that leave
everyone better off
in summary competition usually leads to
lower prices Innovation and higher
living standards monopolies lead to
higher prices inferior products and
lower living standards we should try to
break up monopolies to support free
market competition to learn more about
competition tell us how you would
compete
first find a product or service
available online or in your neighborhood
with very little competition describe
the service and tell us why you think
there is little competition is it
because of a monopoly or because the
demand is so low that there is little
profit to be made or is there another
reason now assume you are opening a
competing business tell us three things
that you would do in order to compete
[Music]
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com